készülj fel egy interjúra a chat gpt
segítségével tegyük fel készülünk egy
céghez és interjúra szeretnénk készülni
a chat gpt kiválóan tudja szimulálni ezt
az interjút először is rákereshetünk
magára a cégre megkérhetjük a chat gpt-t
hogy segítsen megérteni hogy ez a cég
mivel foglalkozik pontosan és valójában
melyek azok a kérdések amelyekre
számíthatunk akár megkérhetjük a chat
gpt-t hogy tegye fel ezeket a kérdéseket
és a válaszaink alapján segítsen hogy
minél inkább fel tudjunk készülni minél
pontosabb válaszokat tudjunk adni
gyakorlatilag egy fél óra alatt annyira
jól fel tudunk készülni egy ilyen
interjúra hogy talán mi magunk is meg
fogunk lepődni összességében azt látom
hogy az ai az egy hatalmas lehetőséget
is hoz egyben veszélyt is viszont
azáltal hogy megismerjük és elkezdjük
tudni használni inkább kikerekedik az
előny oldala mint a veszély oldala és
azt látom az egyetlen lehetőség arra
hogy jóra tudjuk használni azt hogyha
meg megismerjük ezt a a az ai adta
lehetőséget és nap mint nap megtanuljuk
használni